you think this chick that said that uh
no two woman-led countries would go to
war
did you see this
i did see this
this is uh the c-o-o i believe of
facebook which is now called meta yeah
yeah um and uh she said no two women
like country would go to war there's
actually uh no statistics to support
this at all there was actually more war
when there was uh
queens in charge of countries
uh more aggression between countries
when there's men but actual war there's
really no statistical support i've never
seen an episode of housewives yeah yeah
real talk
motherfu [ __ ] what about all them
karen's on your app do you think they're
so reasonable
oh they're carrying videos on facebook
y'all haven't seen no camera videos on
facebook yeah my [ __ ] matters my [ __ ]
does matter okay this [ __ ] over
here trying to act like women wouldn't
get busy 100 they're gonna get busy 100
i think they're going straight to nukes
just off rip
yes yeah guys just do that we just
almost fight all the time you talk a lot
of [ __ ] don't really do nothing hold me
back
hey you got something to say do
something then do something that's what
the u.s and russia did for 40 straight
years
yeah you want to go outside that's every
guy i would fight you but we got to go a
different location and then maybe then
i'll fight you
but it's raining so maybe after noon or
something yeah we got to do this
honorably yeah
that's facts maybe women were in charge
and then men had to there was just so
much warren carnage that men had to like
take control and take power yeah like
i'm talking about like thousands of
years ago maybe there's a time where
women actually ranch it yeah and then
men had to go no no no we're all just
gonna continue dying if we keep this up
yeah maybe
i'm just saying
maybe maybe it seems pretty really
logical
it seems pretty reasonable dude i don't
know if that's supported by any history
i don't know about that that might be as
historical as this yeah the logic is
sound
i don't know about history but the logic
well think about it there used to be
that uh amazonian tribe
they're gone oh
what happened all the women run tribes
are gone because they killed each other
out and now there's only one amazon run
by jefferson and one by jeff yeah well
i'll sing in the rain forest and what's
happening in the rain forest it's dying
okay yeah also that it's not
uh
i think we're onto something and i think
for all of our safety we got to make
sure that men are in charge that's the
ac kicking back on miles don't you worry
okay we got to stay cool in here but you
got to look at countries that are led by
women now that aren't in any war and
they're like which way germany germany
back when it was run by men lots of wars
now there's a woman in charge not that
many wars yeah but that says we shut
that [ __ ] down
we put our foot down say never again
right dove never again
never again can you name other female
leaders
yes
go
i don't want to kamala harris yeah also
kamala harris hey she'd be locking
everybody up bruh she loves she pro-war
as [ __ ] i mean we non-war we kind of
[ __ ] right now bro
hey hey i think we're handling this
perfectly all right everybody
everybody's doing their part yeah we're
doing our part other people out there
doing their part
and we're trying to
make life
as easy as it can be to live out
oh maggie margaret thatcher
she was getting busy to falklands
she was [ __ ] people up south africa
put apartheid in south africa endearing
put it in pretty much i think wow
pretty much
pretty much i think was not the answer i
was looking for
i think she was the architect of
apartheid bro
really i think so which is
a name
architect of apartheid just kind of said
that right now but someone sounds too
good if she was a pro boxer that's the
champ yeah
that's the chance she calls all this
like terrorism racism she gets to be an
architect the titan of terror the
architect of apartheid
come on now fire what about indira
gandhi
who's that akka yeah she [ __ ] a lot of
people up yo okay yeah i don't know she
got assassinated i thought you was
calling gandhi a [ __ ]
who was this cruella deville looking ass
chick right here bruh yeah she got
assassinated
indian politician central figure of uh
indian national congress yeah was she
related
she i they got four last names over
there bro
i think she was the daughter of
something shut up you know you all know
[ __ ]
she was the daughter of an indian person
really anyway the daughter of someone
named ghandi yeah no [ __ ]
but you can double check that for sure
and then she got assassinated for what
uh she
called on a raid of actually sick uh
gurdwara the golden temple she called on
a raider there because she thought there
were some separatists that were hiding
out there and it's like a holy place and
she was like i don't give a [ __ ]
run up in there kill whoever you gotta
kill and then three of her bodyguards
are sick and they're like why not okay
[ __ ] let's see about this and then she
got killed and then there was a massive
massacre of six in 1984 like it was
crazy that's why i have cousins who were
born after me like 85 86 and my parents
were like don't name them sing change
their last name they're like legit like
roy's last name was in sing
because
people might think you're saying let's
just take this guy out oh wow
god damn boy yeah it was wild it was a
wild time
god damn wild time
they were just getting slaughtered i
have in-laws who were like [ __ ]
running and hiding in alleys like crazy
stories but yeah apparently the study
proves it that women wage more war than
men did we know that we go home every
day
this is not lost on us i don't like this
study though because it says it ranged
the european actions from 1480 to 1913.
seems like it comes that's pretty
convenient convenient time to
stop measuring the studies yeah right
i i love what they do that when they're
like uh
white males are the the
america's greatest terrorists
uh a study that started in september
[Applause]
you